en su pueblo catalán
[Música]
dolors bassa fue liberada después de
tres años tras las rejas por la
organización del referendo ilegal de
así que es una dicha estar en casa con
todos ustedes
les agradezco porque no habrían podido
resistir más de 1200 días en prisión sin
ustedes esta ex consejera regional fue
condenada por sedición y desviación de
faltas
abandonó su cerca nueve años antes de lo
previsto una salida anticipada permitida
gracias al indulto concedido por el
gobierno central socialista el indulto
sólo es para la gente que está en la
cárcel ahora somos nueve personas pero
dentro de poco puede haber otras
personas
en cambio la amnistía sería para los más
de 3000 represaliados que tenemos en el
país
malo
tres años más tarde nada ha cambiado
porque todo está perfecto porque todo
queda por hacer
continuaremos todo es posible
su objetivo sigue siendo el mismo
obtener la independencia de cataluña es
una puerta abierta a una solución
política para empezar a hablar de
política
según sus amigos de infancia a estas
liberaciones permitirán relanzar el
movimiento
bueno problemas que leyendo estamos los
plantados de nuevas plantas
la gente fue atemorizada cuando cortaron
las cabezas de los dirigentes políticos
catalanes y en los miembros de la
sociedad civil pero seguimos movilizados
en ningún caso porque son tan libres y
esto es una es un gran acontecimiento
pero bueno la lucha sigue
en barcelona nos reunimos con ferrán
durante un congreso este diputado
socialista del parlamento regional
defiende la decisión tomada por madrid
es lo necesario para procurar que se
abra un nuevo tiempo en cataluña lo que
no era una alternativa es seguir como
estábamos ahora los problemas que se
ignoran y se abandonan van pudriéndose y
van haciéndose cada vez más complicados
de resolver le apuesta al cansancio de
los militantes y no le teme a la
organización de un nuevo referéndum
lo puedan hacer ahora en que el
agotamiento entre sus bases es palpable
en la división estratégica es enorme y
digamos el poco entendimiento entre sus
líderes es aún mayor
xavier representa al colegio de los
economistas catalanes para apaciguar la
región solicitan más igualdad en la
redistribución del presupuesto
cataluña que aproximadamente un 16 por
ciento de la población aporta un 19% y
recibe un 14 ese diferencial se está
repitiendo y eso lo que hace es que el
desequilibrio se vaya perpetuando en
cataluña la población sigue dividida
la presidencia de la región en manos de
los independentistas exhibe dicha
bandera un mensaje que irrita a los
militantes unionistas
hacer referencia a qué
como si los presos políticos hubieran
sido presos simplemente por expresar sus
opiniones en vez de haber infringido la
constitución y las leyes vigentes es la
tendencia de la propaganda separatista
desde hace más de 30 años intentar
desacreditar la democracia española y
presentar a españa como un país
dictatorial
la mayoría de los españoles rechaza
estos indultos gubernamentales muchos
los consideran como una traición la
sensación de humillación y vejación
ultraje es tremendo esto no se va a
pasar tan fácilmente e intentaría es que
es mucho es mucho lo que acumulamos hay
creen hay quienes creen que quizás tres
años ya sea cerró heridas no nos han
cerrado de vidas aquí lo que ocurrió fue
muy grave muy grave a nosotros nos han
querido hacer extranjeros en la tierra
que nos voy a hacer de acuerdo y además
este impulso o sea a cambio de nada
porque ni siquiera lo han solicitado los
golpistas ni siquiera se han arrepentido
y además han insistido en que lo
volverán a hacer esto sólo se explica
por los intereses a corto plazo del
gobierno porque su mayoría es muy exigua
y depende absolutamente de los votos de
los gobernantes de los diputados
separatistas
un concepto compartido por la oposición
política de derecha el partido popular
ciudadanos y box radicaron recursos ante
la justicia hemos recurrido los indultos
porque nos parece que es un engaño al
sistema judicial y siempre que la
separación de poderes está en jaque box
este rey para reparar la que tienen
privilegios que otros españoles que
otros cercanos no tienen por tanto lo
que nos gustaría es que el tribunal
supremo- suspendiera la concesión de
estos indultos que a nuestro juicio se
produce una manera regular y los volver
a meter la cárcel para que cumplir su
condena como el resto de los presos
comunes estos partidos de la oposición
esperan que la izquierda pagara esta
decisión impopular durante las
elecciones generales de 2024